hey everybody its Jessie and today I
guess who will start out I want to start
out by explaining what I've found out
since yesterday about some of the things
we were talking about but then also some
of the errors that have been reported
that others have been getting and I
finally started getting them too and I
think I know why so it would be
worthwhile to go over that and then that
way maybe we can solve the problem
finally or at least at least work around
it after that we're gonna work on this
scroll kind of the scroll spy thing
where it'll this will highlight as we
scroll down whatever section that we're
on we'll be able to click on one of
these and take us to the correct section
alright so first let's let's go over
some of these errors and I also had said
in the description for this video and
for in the the tweet that we were going
to talk specifically about property
initializer syntax so if you want to
check that out in the react Docs if you
go under the handling events page about
halfway down a little more than half way
down they go over the property
initializer syntax and we're using this
in places and this is causing an error
so basically it's instead of binding
this and then in this case its handle
click and then calling handle click but
or anything you know we really want to
call instead of doing that we're using
an arrow fun
which is basically automatically taken
care of binding this and it works so
that the pages obviously work so for
instance on this page we're using we're
using that several times to make this
work we can see that it is working we
can click around and there's no errors I
check the console earlier and that no
errors at all so it works the problem is
when we're we're using standard J s to
help keep our code nice and clean and
always formatted the same way so that's
where the errors are coming from it's
it's not that it's not working it's just
that that's an advanced the react Doc's
say experimental it's an experimental
feature in JavaScript so these are the
errors that we're getting you make this
a bit bigger and let's see so it's
looking something like this
so it's saying like onmouseover is not
defined handle close is not defined
right even we it state is not defined
when we try to define state and kind of
the shorthand way that we've been doing
at at times instead of inside the
constructor so all of these errors are
basically the same thing it's using that
property initializer syntax so initially
when we first started this project and
even in our last project I think we did
the same thing we weren't getting errors
at least I wasn't getting errors and
some of you are getting errors
I started getting errors when I upgraded
yarn to a new newer version and a little
before that I also upgraded NPM although
that that didn't matter for me but
you'll see in a minute I'll explain why
that probably matters for some of you so
I was using a very outdated version of
yarn and I didn't realize that at first
because I kept doing the auto updates
and then it hit me like wow I'm I'm
being asked to update this very
frequently and so I finally checked the
versions and realized that every time I
did that auto update it didn't change
anything I was still in the same version
so I was running yarn like version 18
and now I think I'm on 24 whatever the
latest one is I'm on that so what I
think happens and this is based on going
through some issues and create react app
and issues with es lint
so I spent way too much time researching
this but finally what I think happened
is that something changed in both yarn
and NPM so if you went from NPM for
something you know to NPM version 5 I
think 5 the latest it also the same
thing happen whereas they're handling
one of one or more of the dependencies
differently than they were before
at least that's I don't know technically
how yarn and NPM do things and what
exactly change but that seems to be the
conclusion on that I found like I said
from looking at the issues that other
people have had on the github
repositories for create react app and I
think it was for es LAN or perhaps like
for babel something like I can't
remember what the other repository was
but that was the conclusion basically
and some of the issues had been closed
in particular in
correcta react app there's an issue
basically the same thing that's
happening to us and it's been closed and
the solution which the workaround given
was revert back to NPM version four you
know for dot whatever and the reasoning
given was you know version five there's
there's some different stuff going on
five we don't recommend using that in
production and that was that was it
so couldn't really find a solution and I
don't really want to go back in revert
versions right that's not a great
solution either because not only would I
have to revert but anybody that wanted
to try to run this without errors would
have to revert so that's not really a
good solution so I think that leaves us
with two two ways we could go the first
way is we could just switch everything
back to a less experimental syntax which
has already been suggested so Matt had a
pull request that had did that among
other things and some of you have
already suggested that in the live chat
or in comments to the videos so that's
one way that's probably the easiest way
I mean it would be a little bit of a
pain I guess to go back and do that and
I know Matt's pull request had done that
but we've we've changed something since
then so I can't just pull that in I'd
have to deal with the merge conflicts as
well and the other way that we could go
is try to really figure out what's going
on and and fix the problem so I went
down that path a little a little bit
earlier so I actually did pool Matt's
pool request and he ejected create react
app in that pool request right so my
thought was hey if we eject that I can
go in and change the
figuration of what we're doing with with
es lint and and fix it now also what I
had done is I pulled it in I resolve the
merge conflicts but I purposely left in
some of the newer syntax so whereas Matt
had changed it back to the old version I
wanted to test to see if we could get it
to work so I left some of it in and I
didn't have any success in trying to
change configuration no I will say this
I'm not I'm not really that experienced
with you know dealing with configuring
you know babble and es LAN and standard
js2 all work together so you know maybe
I if I worked on it more I maybe could
get it to work but at this point I think
I'm probably just gonna switch
everything back so and so I do that if
you want to submit a pull request use
this no verify flag on the end so if you
edit a file that doesn't have any of the
the property initializer syntax it will
pass the test so you can see I try to so
I changed this glossary and home right
and I committed that and everything
worked that's because the standard Jas
is only checking the files that had
changed so the only files the change
were these I'm not using that syntax so
it works and this explains why it wasn't
consistent like the errors that people
were getting you know in particular
these errors were not consistent so I
committed that everything was fine but
then a few minutes later I
I tried to commit after changing this
planning ijs where we are using some of
that newer syntax and you can see I got
the errors again all right we have
handle next handle pre not defined so if
you're changing something and you're not
using that syntax you should be fine to
commit otherwise use that know verify
flag at the end for now I don't really
want everyone doing that all the time
because then you know we we won't have
very formatting but I know that this
actually works so I'm not super worried
about it now so what I will do is
convert everything I I really I'd rather
not because I do like the the newer
syntax better but at this point like I
said I just I think I've already spent
way too much time on this issue trying
to find a better solution and if I would
have just changed everything over a
couple days ago then this wouldn't
really have been a problem I wouldn't
have even known that it was a problem so
that's where that's at so I know some of
you have told me that you've had these
issues so they will be I guess not not
really fixed but will work around them
will avoid them by going with the older
syntax for now all right so any any
input you know that you'll have any any
ideas in regard to that I'm definitely
open open to that so probably at some
point maybe tomorrow I'll change the
I'll change the syntax but for now
we're just gonna we're gonna go ahead
and everything we do we're just gonna
commit with that no verified flag and I
just remembered I'm gonna take a minute
here on my other screen to check my mic
level I had a comment on one of the
recent videos that someone couldn't hear
me so I'm gonna double-check
okay looks like the level the level it
should be fine so my output volume is
all the way up on for the settings for
my Mac and also for the settings in OBS
so I'm not exactly sure what was
happening but I don't think there's
anything else I can do about it on my
end so let me know if the sounds alright
for you all but I definitely I wanted to
at least check it out double check and
make sure it wasn't it wasn't anything
that I was going wrong so let me check
the live chat quickly just say hello to
everyone before we get into the coding
I'll bring over the Pomodoro timer and I
also want to apologize yesterday I had
said that the the secondary stream on
Instagram would be available to view for
24 hours afterwards and it wasn't so I
got some sort of error and it said that
the stream wasn't available I think it
was because I waited too long to hit the
share button because it's happened to me
at least one time before so I apologize
for that if anybody was looking for the
stream and couldn't find it I'll try to
remember to hit that share button right
away this time
okay so Sebastian in the in the live
chat is saying pray for Barcelona so if
I remember correctly Sebastian your you
are in in Spain right not correct so
anyway yeah definitely yeah I'll keep
keep Barcelona in my prayer is everybody
affected by by what happened it happened
today so I I just I read a little bit
about it earlier so from what I
understand correct me if I'm wrong
someone drove a car into a group of
people or a van so I didn't get to see
what the if there were you know
casualties from that I am assuming that
at the very least there's some serious
injuries so that's about all I know
about it but yeah definitely I will I'll
be praying for everybody okay cool so so
but Sebastian is in Spain but not close
to Barcelona so well I'm glad to hear
that you're all right Sebastian and yeah
so anyway so anyway everybody watching
who who engages in prayer
definitely definitely be good to get
some prayers going for that situation
alright so for same ones
oh goodness Sebastian says that the
reports are saying that they're anywhere
from 1 to 13 people deceased from from
what had happened so I'm gonna take just
a second to pray silently for those
people just
all right
okay let's see we try to go all uh I'm
gonna get started now and I guess if
anybody's tracking what's happening if
there's anything like any you know
important news or anything comes up
about that you know keep us up-to-date
I'm not I'm not going to be able to
follow it while I'm doing the stream but
just have had a few kind of basic
questions that I'll answer now since
they're at the top of the stream I don't
want to lose them later on
braxton ask Jeff see if you completed
the free code camp course like
everything or what parts actually no I
haven't completed it so I haven't even
finished the front end certificate so
I'm slightly ashamed to say that I have
not finished that so you know I go
through it and you just get usually what
happens is I get busy with with work and
I just I don't I don't work on it like I
should and now that I'm doing the
Udacity course the react nanodegree I've
been putting off the free code camp
stuff so I don't know I don't think I
have my free code camp profile linked
anywhere right now I probably should do
that and then you all can check out my
progress I really I do intend on going
through the rest of the free code cam at
some point but definitely not so after
I'm done with my react course which
should be I think November I think the
course ends in November so it'll be a
little while but also okay there's
another question but you'll cover that
in the live chat so thank you
yeah okay so Sebastian that says so you
are saying the tests are failing because
of newer he s six syntax yes it's
actually boa it would be what are they
calling es 6 + es 7 so I'm not really
sure what at what stage the property
initializer syntax is right now I was
reading some things about the stage but
I think some of the stuff I was reading
was old so I'm not sure that it that
it's still up to date but but in any
case that's basically the the issue
alright so for now I want to kind of
move forward with with this and you know
maybe maybe we'll find a better solution
to it
but at least for now we can work on this
so what I've was working on and what we
left off with yesterday was we need to
find we need to track the scroll
position so we need to know two things
we need to know the the position on the
page of each one of these there h3 tags
so we need to know that position just in
terms of I guess they're pixels from the
top from the top of the page and then we
need to track the scroll position so we
could get the scroll position pretty
easily so you'd see I just doing some
things in the console here so we can do
document dot body scroll top okay and
this gives us I believe it's the number
of pixels from the top that we've
scrolled so if you could see we
we're at the top it comes back as zero
scroll down a bit and comes back 587 so
we've got one covered the next thing we
need to know is the the position of
these elements so actually I had a
little trouble so I assumed like hey I
can just get the scroll top position of
this and they kept returning zero so I
looked into it and on mdn I was it was
saying basically this doesn't work on
every element so if the element is non
scrollable or if it has no overflow its
scroll top is always zero
so
I'm just I'm wondering what the kind of
what we should do
I kind of want to see if I could just
change the overflow and make it work in
here I didn't really matter I guess what
I said it too
now we're still getting ya are still
getting that so maybe I need to target a
different a different element
yeah let me try to target a different
element that might be the easiest thing
to do unless I'm using that close up in
the wrong way
okay Matt says be careful about using a
spy scroll for on page load if you have
dynamic data updating the page and it
changes the height you might get the
wrong body height I should have this
page should be alright just in terms of
I don't think we'll have any dynamic
data for this page it's this is just
going to be pretty straightforward but
wool I mean we'll we'll see if we have
issues with it so let me I'm just going
to take this ID and put it on this div
just to see if we can get a different
result
no we're not I I'm wondering if I'm
using the wrong thing if this maybe is
not what I should be looking for I know
I've done all this before I've done it
all before but I I I kind of think I did
it in jQuery before so I'm not sure that
my my old code would be very much help
to look it up
basically what I'm looking for is I need
the the Y position of an element an HTML
element on the page
mmm
get boning box yeah I was each other
let's see
okay so this is one way to do it
okay
I there's got to be some way to get
right right to this right this is what I
want but you would think there would be
some way that I could just get this oh
well we can do this for now
so let's
let's move this back onto our h3 so it
should work we'll double check make sure
that it does work okay
that's working so here's what we need to
do on on page on component amount we're
going to get the values we're gonna
these values for each one of those h
threes then on scroll we're going to get
the user scroll position once the scroll
position gets to this top coordinate for
one of those sections then we'll change
the state so that one of these will be
highlighted so let's that's the plan so
let's let's do that let's go over to our
code and make it a bit bigger and
so for now let's see
okay so our step index
I think our step index just gets a
number okay so that's just zero index
number so in this case
I guess we could just get all the eights
trees on the page I was thinking we'd
have a different ID for each h3 but I
don't know that we don't know that we
need to do that
oops
okay so Matt had typed in a live chat
try doing offset height and I had done
that before but I kept getting 46 and
there's no way that this is 46 pixels
from the top so that's why I didn't go
with that
so maybe I'm doing wrong
hey so anyway so aim aim highs here if
you're it's been a while how's it going
right now we're working on the scroll so
we're gonna get the scroll position and
we're gonna change basically this it's
going to highlight this menu in the side
based on what section we're on in the
world so you'll be able to click on a
section and then it'll take you right to
that section actually we will need our
anchor tags right because there are our
IDs yeah so let's give these IDs
sign ahead
budget
proof
services okay
now see if we have I don't think we yeah
we don't have a component didn't mount
in here yet
so let's add that in Odin did mount and
that's not sure if we'll need that but
in terms of being able to access this
but we might cements will put it in
actually probably will because we need
to access state let's see
I'm trying to think of a way that I
could get all these without having to
manually call the get the ID so maybe
see
that's AG h3
get elements by tag name okay cool so
yeah we can get you can just get this
and most of the ID ID something okay
okay Alberto has given another another
option here that we can try out and that
might be the winner offset top that's
what I think that's what we were looking
for so yeah that's what we're looking
for so that's the right value Thank You
Alberto I knew I knew that there was
something that would give us what we
wanted so that's it so to get the height
or I'm sorry to get the the position of
an element in terms of how many pixels
from the top it is then offset top is
the way to go if you need more
information just get bounding client rec
will give you a lot of information but
we don't need that in our case okay
great
so
all right so here's what I'd like to do
I'd like to get when within component
did mount I'd like to get all the h3
elements and then save see I guess we
could save that as key value pairs with
the ID and the whatever value we get
from offset top and that should be all
the information we need about those
those age tags okay does that make sense
if not let me let me know in the live
chat
okay slightly off what we're doing right
now but so Patrick has been kind of
giving updates on trying to replicate
those errors we were talking about at
the beginning of the the stream and he
couldn't replicate it but then Patrick
installed node version eight point four
point zero and now the errors are
occurring so yeah so that's that's no
good I mean anybody that's keeping their
stuff up to date is gonna get errors so
that's not what we want all right so
let's let's go with
what's gonna console.log that the double
check make sure that that works before
we go forward
cuz that's pretty important shoot and
it's not giving us anything why not
the
all right either we're doing something
wrong maybe it's not the right place to
put it I'm I'm not even getting any
errors the not really much I can I can
do
okay now Patrick went back to an earlier
version of note he's still getting the
heirs yeah it this is it's it's
frustrating it was a fresh ending
experience for me Sebastian says he's on
note eight point two point one and not
getting any errors so yeah it's just it
it's really difficult to nail down
exactly exactly what's going on I mean
all I know is that I update and I get
the errors and I never got them before
all right so good thanks so am i had the
suggestion just log a string and see if
component did mountain is even getting
called and no it's not what what's going
on
three items in my feelings
you're not getting
it's it's alright so I'm not seeing
anything but I'd saying that I'm having
items hidden by filters but I I'm not
sure that I have anything filtered
maybe this is who knows let's see no
that's not all right well for some
reason we're not we're not getting
component did not
see if we can get anything to show up
that's that's really odd
you
all right so
not sure
I'm not sure why I can't get a console
look I'm checking in the live chat now
see what would you or thinking
Yosef says today no thumbs down we
really should celebrate
ya know thumbs down yet we'll see I
usually always get one or two
okay let's see what's going on yeah it
should be yeah I mean that this should
be what we proposed only to fall whoa
okay so that fixed it
okay somehow I had I guess turn these
off anyway
Wow so it looks like this worked so
let's see what did I change let's go
back to what I initially had to see if
it works
there we go all right
okay
never use
so this is what is now our we name that
headers so we should be able to grab
what's that again okay it's just ID so
we can grab the ID and then with the ID
we could get that
what was it offset top yeah we can use
offset top to get that value right
now the david said it was probably a
chrome update or something that caused
that it's so annoying when things like
that change actually now you say that i
did update chrome but yesterday i think
i updated on this computer yesterday so
that's that's possible because I don't
remember changing that but I do remember
that I haven't seen any errors in the
console for a while so that was probably
what
all right so now that we've gotten
through that kind of a silly silly
problem now let's go through us we're
gonna do the headers
I think with the best way to go through
these headers would be
we met
I guess we could map right oh I know I
was corrected in an earlier stream but
we can map over an array correct that's
the proper use of map I think I tried to
map over an object before and that was
not the way to do it
so Hale says can you invite me to the
slack chat I don't think you need an
invite you just need the the link
correct it should so Blake pasted a link
in there in the live chat so if you copy
that and then replace the asterisk with
asterisk with a period then it should
work let me know if that link does not
work it says you okay so it does say you
need an invite that's weird is anybody
else does anyone else have that same
issue of needing an invite
whoa patrick said linting fixed PR
incoming patrick if you really fixed the
linting i'm gonna be super happy and
like very very impressed because this
has been what like we've been streaming
for less than an hour and it took me
probably fifteen minutes to explain what
the problem is so that's very impressive
it's like you've you've probably fix
this issue in less time than it took me
to explain the issue
all right here is an invite link to join
the slack thing I pasted it in the live
chat try that out and let me know if
that works alright so anyway where where
is that I got distracted okay okay so we
want to do
in the States
it is
mmm
okay yep I think that's what I want to
do so we can check that out
nope that's not gonna work all right
wait a second
yeah it was I I D was the I was there
right
see
is this just a syntax thing did I mess
that up at least
No
it's
visited
okay
maybe do I need
do I even need this
okay
thank you too
maybe I didn't need that
it's
there's my error message this is my
error message headers done that it's not
a function
and today I just can't I can't do
anything without getting an error
how about
- it
right I say my says do array is array by
station
let's see
let's see
Serio give us
okay so thanks I'm Berto for that
suggestion and then I don't need yeah
correct okay just so yeah so then we
don't really need when in here I was
using the the ID to get that element but
since it's returning elements anyway
I don't need that I can just go straight
to straight to this so
okay so still getting this Heather's map
that map is not a function
I actually was I thinking I didn't want
to set up my state like that I wanted to
have
let's see
let's just loop through this in a simple
way
all right so I'm gonna be old-fashioned
here for for a second
yeah
did I mess up in a for-loop
I'm pretty sure I did not mess up the
forlán
yeah
it's your iteration condition uh I did
myself a for loop I'm very so good good
look it up man I just that may be my
most embarrassing moment on a live
stream that I I messed up a for loop by
putting the putting the greater than
sign instead of the less than sign it's
not like I haven't done that before but
I've never done that live on YouTube
alright I just looked over at my
analytics for this video I was expecting
everybody to just quit watching at this
point but it looks like it didn't happen
okay Matt said you might be able to use
a for each loop instead of for loop yeah
I figured I could use something else but
I just thought like I'm just gonna go
like to the simplest thing I can think
of just to test it out so that could
probably be refactored I'm actually I'm
still not exactly sure why I couldn't
get mapped to work I I don't know so
does doesn't matter for loops are fun so
hey look we have all the values that we
want now we just need to put that I'm
gonna put that in state so that we can
can access that
actually doing need that in state let me
think about our next step needs to be so
now that we can get we can get that we
need to compare waste we need have us
scroll handler to listen for the scrolls
and then compare okay yes so probably
in scroll position should also be in
state
and we could just start that at zero
because that's probably where it'll be
anyway
okay let's get rid of a lot of this
so I'm just thinking of trying to think
ahead trying to think if I even need the
the IDs to be in state
I'm not sure if I'd I need them to be in
stay right now
and their positions
okay so
Tomer Hey welcome I don't know that I've
seen you in the live chat before but
welcome and also a good call so summer
says document dog get elements by tag
name returns an HTML collection not an
array that probably explains why I
couldn't use map so thank you for that
sebastian is also saying could you do
something like this if the scroll
position of the first h 3 is less than X
set step index to 1 which is the first
step if the second H 3 is less than X
set step index to 2 and so on
yeah yeah Sebastian that's I think
that's the way to go
John also asked our props not usually
the way to go first before using state I
keep seeing this so I'm not sure John
I'm actually I I frequently do you state
just two stores store data in state and
I don't know that I necessarily need to
I guess I don't really know what the the
best way to do it is but with some some
things obviously you do want to be in
state like if you want if you want
things to happen when values change then
she put it in state
what they're doing
[Music]
what's the
the new what's it called the new es6
syntax is a spread operator can I use
that in this case to add things on
I just kind of freaked I forget what the
sin let me look up the syntax on the
other screen because it would be cool to
use this properly in the video I was
just I was just going over this fright
night does it maybe like two weeks ago I
was going over this so I don't use it
often enough to remember how to use it
it's something like this right it's
really we want to combine
combined arrays so
I guess I could just say that and see
I'm pretty sure that's not all that I
need but let's see yeah
oh yeah cuz I'm not this this is not an
array so I guess I could just go with
whoops that's not
oh cool Andrew says in the official
documentation Facebook has a great
section on how to determine when you'll
need state it really helped make sense
of things for me all right good to know
so if you're curious about when to you
state and when not to you state check
that out I made I should probably check
that out as well since since I'm not
able to really explain how I decide when
to you state and when not to you state
then I think I need more information on
that I mistake he need to okay cool
can cat-eye good thanks Sebastian that
was exactly what I needed I was thinking
in my head like what is it do I use push
or pop or what you know those are things
to handle a raise and I'm trying to
remember what's the one that would add
it to the end but this works this well
yes
loose
what
you know come on
what is going on here
this is like
okay that's it King cab returns an array
which does not use AIDS Day
all right let's see I'm getting some
some suggestions here in the live chat
so let me go through some of these by
Patrick says can Cat returns an array
thereby not mutating state
and
you just build the array in the for loop
and then add it to state all right cool
I'm Barrett oh yeah that makes a lot of
sense
all right cool let's do that so I don't
remember if I read America's coming out
loud or not but I'm better just said why
not just create the array in the loop
and then add the array after that to
state and that that that makes a lot of
sense so let's do that
way what was Sebastian say
okay Sebastian says do do the same as in
component we'll update next crops next
state and then consider position from
next state yeah you need to set the
state outside of the loop yeah all right
let's get this out of here
okay
okay sorry I'm not usually accused of
talking too much in my streams I feel
like I'm not really saying very much of
all what I'm typing so anyway what so
what I'm doing here is we have basically
we've made an empty array here that's
our header positions that's going to
hold our values inside this loop we are
pushing the values here our offset top
values into the array so then we're
gonna call this set state and let's see
we don't need this anymore we need
header positions is going to be
their positions
okay
so you need to do right
and probably don't need to initialize
that into right let me just see what it
says first Oh didn't get an error that's
a good sign
really
sweet look at that no dang it it's not
the right values okay but we have
something all right so we've
successfully put something into state
all right man
this is this has been rough this it's
like every single step something goes
wrong all right so why why is this
happening he had a position oh because I
put zero and I needed I alright that's
I'm happy about that that's easy to fix
yeah there we go
right so here's all our positions
wonderful so just just in case you
didn't fall along this maybe especially
if you're new to JavaScript the the
error that I was having was that I I put
0 here which was giving me the first
element in our headers array and then
getting the offset top of that element
which is why we had the same value for
each one what I needed to do was put I
here right and I is going to be 0 1 2 3
4 each time this loop goes it's gonna go
up by 1 and that gave us the value that
we needed ok wonderful
are you haven't looked at the live chat
for a few minutes and the did you tell
someone that I'm using notepad
yeah okay so Sebastian said doing it
like I'm doing now I don't need this
yeah you're right I didn't I don't need
these and okay I figured I may have left
the console log in there as well but I
think I got them all out
Oh slip slip sack no had he caught my my
error with putting the the zero in here
instead of the ISO thanks for catching
that sorry I didn't look over and see it
so you must have caught that right away
so guess good job on that
okay so sue sahib is saying I'm not
understanding anything anybody who can
help alright so I'm not I'm not exactly
sure what your level of understanding is
in terms of like JavaScript or react or
anything so I'm not exactly sure where
to start but we're using a JavaScript
framework called react to build this so
it's not exactly just plain JavaScript
but within this what we're doing here is
mostly just plain JavaScript and that
we're just grabbing the header tags all
of the header tags on the page we have
this gives us an array of the the
elements or not exactly an array but
this gives us all our elements and then
we're just looping through those
elements and we want to get the position
of each of those elements on the page in
terms of how many pixels from the top of
the page it is so that's where that
offset top is so we now have an array
called header positions it gives us the
position from the top in pixels of each
one of the h3 elements on our page and
our page being this page so these are h3
s and we have four h3 s right and then
this is the react part of it all this
was just regular JavaScript the react
part is that were only set state right
which our state is up here and we're
going to set this portion of our state
which is header positions we're going to
set that equal to our header positions
that we've put in here and this is block
scoped right so it's not we're not going
to be able to access this anywhere else
in terms of this this variable but we
will be able to access it through state
all right so that's what we've got now
the whole point of getting that I'm not
sure if you've been watching the whole
time or not so you may not have heard
towards the beginning but the whole
point of getting that is that we want to
be able to track where a user is on the
page as they scroll down and then show
that visually by highlighting this menu
over here which we haven't each one of
these menu items is going to correspond
to one of these H tags so as the user
Scrolls the corresponding section here
will be highlighted and they can click
to go to whatever section they want so
that's that's I guess where we're at so
hopefully that made more sense of this
for you all right
good
all right so I have not taken a break
since we started well almost since we
started to look at the live chat so I'm
gonna do that even though I remembered
to pull this over on my screen I never
started it so let's take a five-minute
break I'm gonna go to the live chat see
if I missed any questions and to be
honest with you I need the 5-minute
break right now because we just I don't
want to say we but I just struggled
through that that was that was rough it
was it was rough on my my mental stamina
here so I can feel like I just need a
small break and then we'll we'll get
back to it
okay going through I guess I didn't miss
miss many questions here in the lab chat
so that's good
Ali asked a while ago if there are good
resources for people who are not too new
who are not too new with JavaScript
sebastian recommended free code camp
yeah that would be my recommendation to
free code camp code Academy has some
introductory JavaScript courses that you
can do and then Udacity has some free
internet introductory JavaScript courses
as well so those would be my main
suggestions if you like reading more
than like the hands-on stuff then the
book you don't know j/s is available for
free it's all on github so you can you
know read through that that whole book
for free that's that's really good it's
more like a series not just one book but
those would be my recommendations
okay
okay I mentioned earlier we were talking
about Wendy you state and when not to
use state and I had seen so Andrew had
said that there's a great section in the
react documentation on that and then I
didn't see his follow-up comment which
was the section is called thinking in
react so if you want to go right to that
section
check it out thinking and react is the
place to go John Hanson has a question
this is what about media queries that
can change a component would it be
better to associate that with props or
state
yes
well I guess if we're using media
queries then that would be in CSS so if
it's a CSS change I don't it doesn't
necessarily need to be in props or state
that would that would just be handled
with the media queries in CSS so now if
you wanted I guess if you wanted to use
JavaScript to check the width of the
page and then do things based on that
then
I I would if if I were using javascript
to check the width of the screen and
then let's say every time the whiff
changed you know it updates those values
then I would say the the screen width
which should be in state right the value
of the width of screen should be in
state it should update every time the
window has changed the window width has
changed I suppose I mean I guess that
would be a lot of a lot of changes maybe
you wouldn't want to update every time
yeah that be
I guess I'm just not sure I'm trying to
think of a situation where you would
want to do it that way instead of using
just regular CSS media queries I'm sure
they exist I'm just having trouble
thinking about it a situation like that
right on the spot
at some point hold on I have a knock at
the door I'll be right back
so make sure
okay I'm back
sorry about the little silent few
minutes there but when was the head of
my department when the head of the
department knocks on my door I kind of
have to take that so and that was in
regard to our last project the
catechetical Institute site so I guess
I'll be working on some updates to that
starting October 1st so we'll be going
back to that and hopefully making it
better we'll see we'll see what the
requested updates are okay
see
all right so I've just seen Sebastian
I've seen your latest comments here
saying when I click the link in seek
common Markov terms for more information
for some reason I'm scrolled in the
middle of that page seems that depending
on your scroll position and planning
guide you did a different scroll
position in glossary yeah that's that's
not what we want and that's that's odd
and so this that's that's really odd
behavior I would think the default
behavior for react router actually let's
see if am I using the link there
properly
okay I am just linked to glossary all
right you would think the default
behavior would be to scroll up to the
top of the page has anyone had any
experience with this using react router
where it does not scroll to the top of
the page I mean an easy way to fix this
would just be to scroll the page to the
top automatically on component and it
mount but there there's got to be
something in react router about this
let's see I'm just going to add this
okay
okay Matt said I ran into a similar
issue and used window scroll top or
window dot scroll to zero zero zero on
route change okay cool that's what I was
well I mean that's what I was thinking
about doing in component did mount but
you can do that I'll just have to look
it up to do that on a route change like
I'm assuming there's like a callback for
route change where you could do that in
with react router so mandela mandela
effect conference asks how did some of
you guys posting learn react for us noob
so i guess that's not directed at me
it's directed at you all in the end a
live chat so let's he lets you handle
that i think
I think I've explained this before I'm
sure how I've learned places where I've
learned react from so unless you all
have in the live chat have a turn now
all right where we at let's see we have
we need to get that some values in that
side navigation the secondary navigation
now
okay so I guess this is where we're
gonna do whatever we need to do so index
okay so we still need a we need to check
for this scroll
all right so I have to check the
okay so what we want to do inside
component did mount we're gonna call
track scroll and when we're tracking the
scroll we want to add an event listener
okay
so we want to we already added this
escape right yeah
and how are we getting this girl
position before was
document.body scroll table yeah
yes that's where we don't
all right let's see if this works this
state there's not as much
see
okay yeah matt said d balance that
function yeah I definitely I don't want
to leave it like this I just wanted to
see if it worked but yeah you definitely
don't want to run that every single time
that there's any activity on the scroll
so let me see
something so inside here this is not
this is not this it's not working so can
I turn this
I suppose if I use an arrow function
then I would have access to it so we can
change this too
see
oops
okay Matt Matt's pasting in a bunch of
stuff here so I just saw that Matt
alright so let me let me go through
okay sis it's a lot of stuff going on
let me taste some of this so thank you
bet
alright so we had a handle scroll and
then whoops
here we go
okay
I think I got that copied over correctly
in the right place so I guess we should
let me check to make sure I did it right
and it works and then we'll all explain
what's going on
oops I did not bring in do you sure I
know I'm bringing this in somewhere else
let me there we go
okay
great okay so let's inspect this and
check the state and they're really
scroll position
okay so it's actually it's updating
scroll while which is fine so let's get
rid of scroll position here well we can
why okay so that works let me explain
what's going on alright so the first
thing that happens and component did
mount it calls track scroll track scroll
then adds an event listener so that
every time the user Scrolls this this
happens right but then we're using D
bounce from low - right which is a
JavaScript library so we've imported D
bounce from low - basically what this is
doing is making sure that this handle
scroll does not get called constantly so
this is a 300 millisecond delay try
think this there's a couple of different
ways aside from so like there's D
balance and I think there's throttle I
can't remember for sure the difference
in terms of what it when it's calling
this but basically it's just going to
make sure that this doesn't fire all the
time so when handle scroll does get
called then it's going to set the state
and it's going to set scroll why because
it's the Y position right to whatever is
window dot scroll Y and we can see in
our state
oops
so in our state we have the scroll wide
position and let's see if I get these
both on the screen at once we should be
able to see a change as we scroll there
we go okay so there's a scroll
actually I don't think we want to use
debounce
we want to use so if I remember
correctly now debounce
waits until the action has been done so
in this case it'll wait from the time I
stop scrolling 300 milliseconds but I
would like this to change as the scroll
occurs so what we should do is should
use something else so I think we can use
throttle
and let me I'm double checking on my
other screen here
yeah I think throttle is the better way
to go so so debounce what it's going to
do is so as I'm scrolling there's a
bunch of actions going on it's going to
group all those actions into one so you
can see now that I stopped it's it's
grouped all that it's only fire that
once what throttle is going to do is
it's going to make sure that it only
fires let's say every 300 milliseconds
but every 300 milliseconds it will check
that scroll position so it's so I will
get more of what we want if we're gonna
use throttle
so let's see
I think we've got
today where are we bringing the best
does create react app come with with low
- because I'm not seeing it
that's
let's see if that works yeah
that's
there we go all right CeCe this is
giving us let's see if I can get it to
do so as I'm scrolling you see it's
updating and I'm not stopped so that's
more what we want once we get once we
have the changes reflected here we'll be
able to see if we need to set in terms
of the delay in milliseconds you know
maybe we need to go lower to make it you
know more smooth we'll see okay but
basically that's if you're going to use
D bounce or throttle that's like
debounce is really good like if you
wanted to like do validation on an input
field you would want to wait until the
user has stopped typing right see you
know you don't want like the error
message to pop up right in the middle of
what they're typing right you you want
to wait because let's say like for the
email address for instance right if they
haven't got to the point where they
typed like the at and then the domain
obviously anything is that's going to be
invalid so it would be annoying to show
this you want to wait until they've
stopped let's say for 300 milliseconds
because at that point they've you know
they're either thinking or they're
probably done but in the case of
scrolling in this case of scrolling
since we want it to be like more a fluid
thing that it will highlight as we're
scrolling we wanted to go with throttle
so that we know that it'll keep firing
so anyway so hopefully this I've kind of
feel like that's the most intelligent
thing I've done this entire stream is
explain the difference between throttle
and D valves so that also said correctly
that we need to unbind
or remove the eventlistener
so let's do that as well so component
did unmount
nice fellow impunity okay so on
component did unmount we want to remove
that event listener right so we we don't
want that if we're not on this view
there's no reason to have that going
right so
let's remove that
so
cease what I need to put I need to put
do I need to put the rest
alright let let me know if I need to put
the rest of this for it to accurately
remove it or not
else component will I'm not
all right so let's see
let's check our lifecycle methods for
rewrites see which one we want there is
no component did unmount yes I guess we
just need component will unmount which
is cool since do we have it already no
we don't oh we have component will mount
all right we'll we'll announce
that was a pretty useful error message
that are actually it said exactly what
we needed we needed to use okay The
Times
all right so at this point
yeah at this point I'm not sure if I
want to go ahead and try to implement
this whole thing because we've been
going for over two hours and I'm
starting to get pretty hungry and I've
used up a lot of my brainpower
struggling through all the errors I was
getting so I suspect at this point my my
work is going to become the quality of
my work is going to lessen as I keep
trying to get past this point of being
mentally exhausted and hungry so I think
now would be a good time to finish for
today and I'll answer any questions I'll
try to scroll up a bit see if there any
questions but in terms of the code I
think we'll finish for today all I'll
commit this so that you all can see it
in github and I mean we've got a
significant way a significant portion of
this finished the rest of the steps
would then be you know now that we have
this simply comparing our values you
know our Y position our header positions
and then changing the step index based
on that and then once we do that then we
can do things based on the step index
within here those things being highlight
the correct I'm sorry this is what
happens when we click on it actually so
in here this is where we would want to
actually scroll to the place that that
we should be scrolling to but on scroll
depending on the comparison of our Y
position and our header positions we're
gonna highlight something different here
so those are the next steps we'll get to
that either
I may just finish us this up tomorrow
morning and then just show what I've
done
we'll see unless something comes up and
I can't get to it then we'll just work
on it during the stream tomorrow
but if you don't want to stick around
for the question/answer thanks for
watching and thanks for all your help I
really appreciate that I'm actually a
decent number of years stick around to
this point so thank you thank you for
that it's been long and somewhat
difficult today now so I'm gonna scroll
up a bit so I did get most of the way
through all right I'm gonna call them
you see I said I don't think there's any
question so I'm gonna take this phone
call and I will see you all tomorrow
thank you so much for watching